hello there i'm gab i'm dan we're the
slo-mo guys it's a lovely sunny day so
we're gonna mess about
with some liquid metal yeah we've got
some gallium here
this is oh do you know when you expect
something to be much lighter than it is
i thought it was gonna be like water and
i had to lift more than i thought feel
how happy that is
oh yeah yeah so gallium is a metal it
melts at a pretty low temperature
looks almost exactly like mercury but
won't kill you as much
yeah unless you were made out of
aluminium then it would kill you that's
true yeah it like melts aluminium it
just
corrodes it to crumbles yeah so
similarly to what we did with the paint
on the speaker we're going to try it
with this gallium because i think it'll
behave
quite differently yeah it should just
look like a load of liquid mirror
yeah yeah um it is a lot heavier than
paint though so i'm wondering how it's
going to look
on the speaker why don't we turn on the
phantoms and have a little look
yeah all right this is so weird
oh the thud of it it thirds down doesn't
it it's like
globbing look at that how globby it is
you look like a dj of science
science science dj okay we'll start low
and i'll increase the volume and then
we'll see what you want okay
top so pay attention yeah
more than that
whoa it gets so much brighter
yeah yeah that's hurting my eyes
it went i was a bit worried there
because it went
huh it's not working so i turned the
volume up and tried again
as you as it was all flying up in the
air i was looking at this and i was like
how much of this is aluminium
oh goodness me
stop oh look at this
what is happening like that has got to
be a compression nightmare for youtube
what is going on it looks like
evil it looks like aliens isn't it maybe
what they should have done to the t-1000
is vibrate him to death he would just
turn into this
maybe they use sound guns on him can you
imagine if you tried to
simulate this with a computer just all
those
infinite reflections reflections
reflecting reflections
i think the gpu would just melt it's
just like it's just a hot mess
it's so hard to to see depth and like
what is what it's
it's it's almost like we're shooting on
a monochrome camera it looks 2d
that's really weird
again i still don't really know what i'm
looking at
this might be the most unwatchable video
we've ever made
yeah like little solder balls yeah like
i'm just like it's like i'm
like rolling up bogeys of of gallium
into like bigger bogeys look
look at that you're having fun yeah this
is so satisfying you have no idea look
it's like a cross between like silver
and milk
because it has like a skin on it of slag
that you have to sort of wipe off with
this slag remover it does look like slag
doesn't just like
wipe it clean and it has a nice fresh
mirrored
it's so satisfying to do that by the way
yeah that might be the most
gallium i've ever seen in one place
when we started filming today it was the
most gallium i'd seen in one place i've
never seen
gallium before it was like
that's a lot of gallium done on the
speaker it was a
very hard to like again the sun's right
there it's like someone's using their
watch in class you know when you like
twist it around except it's like
all right let's try a nice paw okay you
ready
yep go for it
good i think that was quite quite a good
one yeah
excellent how do you feel about it yeah
goodbye
oh i tried to i tried to grab you
ready yep so i predictively
focus just in front of that lip
it does come out oh look at that shine
there look at that can you see the
camera in the reflection of that
i think you can't you can see like the
trees and the sky you've probably seen
me
three suns there turning into that is
mad that is
it's definitely how the t-1000 was born
yeah it is
it must have been cast just like this
looks like one is being made
oh it looks like oh weird that's quite a
thick
do you know when the t-1000 is
transforming into like a different shape
like
yeah it looks like that they were really
accurate with that back in the day
oh look at those lens flares rippling
off it now it's very cool
and it's like slowly sort of globbing
into the bowl at the bottom there
yeah i like how the stream gets thinner
and thinner as it goes down
and then it turns into like a torrent at
the bottom look at that look at that on
the right hand side there
where it's all bouncing up maybe we
should go in
in tight on that area and just get one
one more paw just from like in the bowl
yeah yeah let's do it three two one
stop looks like the moon
it does i don't know like what do you
look at such a weird sight
oh wow that's weird they look like
diamonds that was a pear that was like a
plum bob from the sims
whoa that's amazing
that warmth it looks like something
like from krypton in man of steel yeah
i'd want to
reverse it and see what it looks like to
like it looks like it's sucking up all
the energy
weird the way it it breaks up
differently to water like it's too heavy
for air to get under
so it stays as like cones
that was a cool bit it's just not really
bouncing it's sort of just
falling into it's just it's just like
really heavy water
yeah it's all like kicking out in the
middle of it and now it's because it's
deeper
it's like because it's so heavy it's
forcing all the other stuff to the side
it makes these weird vertical ripples
coming out
like all the horizontal ones and then
you get this vertical one that's sent
out
i'm pouring it slightly forwards because
that's the nature of pouring you can't
just pour directly down unless you're
far away
so it's creating all these like shooting
forwards all this gubs
that's just creating little giblets
i'm always a big fan of filming liquid
but weird liquid is even better
you excited about this yeah i really am
oh
look at that like creme there
oh yeah
a mirrored surface look at that yeah
there's me like
oh i bunched it i could honestly film
this material all day
okay you may have seen this in the
background of the video so far we
thought it'd be a good idea
to wreck this drum uh goodbye sweet drum
but see if we can get a good hit from
underneath just like when we did that
powder paint
yeah except powder paint weighs a lot
less than you know
metal yeah so i'm gonna pour it on here
and obviously we're in
back garden so it's not even completely
level so it's gonna be like deeper over
here than it is over here
i'm gonna have to go underneath the drum
skin with a spanner
to try and hit it and hopefully we'll
catch most of it in this
child's paddling pool yes right probably
only get one shot of this
all right so the first test is to see
whether the drum can even
hold oh dear
this much liquid god it's all pulling to
the back
so i don't get caked in gallium you need
to tuck you in yeah just take me into
bed
nice that's perfect actually
okay go for it
a little bit of rain
whoa see how it sends it all out to the
sides yeah
and then it hits that's mental
that's so different to do you know
everything else we've put on this
it's because the drum isn't level right
so the way you're seeing it ripple two
and then bounce up is the edge of the
actual liquid
yeah i was deliberately focused on the
front edge because i want to see all
those spikes in focus
you see them all raise up at the front
there that's cool oh man
close it ripples out and then it like
bounces back in
yeah so that's what it looks like to hit
a sheet of liquid metal from underneath
i think i could look at liquid metal all
day well not all day but maybe
20 or so minutes before i got bored i
can't even look at it now
it sucks right there you're not even
stood in it i was wondering why you just
did this here
i guess the only thing to do now then is
to scrape this gallium
back into a container hopefully we still
got enough because i want to use that
again in future that was
that was amazing it's pretty sweet if
you enjoy watching
liquid metals bounce all around let us
know in the comments
feel free to subscribe whack that
picture of a bell for some reason
and we've got a second channel too see
you in the next video
you're gonna get a wicked tan i am
should i just stand it like this
it feels like five minutes on a sunday
you know when people have though that
like
miracle yeah just have gallium